sehen wir schon oh mein gott
löcher meiner lieben frauen und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer weiteren folge
der minecraft commands allerdings muss
ich euch bevor diese folge jetzt so
richtig los geht erst mal sagen dass ich
dem vorproduzieren bin wegen weil ich
nach düsseldorf flieger und nach new
york und nach berlin und so dass in den
nächsten beiden freitags folgen immer
auch nur ein command vorgestellt wird da
ich nicht so viele sachen jetzt wirklich
noch aussuchen dann leicht schon total
am strecken bin ihm vor produzieren und
das wollte ich nur am anderen erfolge
jetzt mal sagen das heißt in dieser
folge und in der folge am dienstag und
am nächsten freitag nochmal immer nur
ein command aber wir fangen deswegen
auch schon direkt an mit dem format und
es werden noch immer recht große command
sein das heißt wir gehen erst mal wieder
ein chat 1 / gfp kommen unterstrich
block setzen in command blockieren ich
nehme hier einen tollen hebel raus
drücke ich hier steuerung frau und füge
den command ein der von mister ghetto
ist und zwar ist es der minions kommen
wir sehen schon hier wird eine maschine
kreiert und jeden moment finden wir an
der maschine kein zeichen dass uns sagt
harry hier sind eine alte muss sondern
da ist ja von mister carretto ist wissen
wir schon da müssen wir selber ans
handwerk greifen müssen selber so ein
bisschen was kreieren wir sehen schon im
chat die minis command has been sold und
das was wir jetzt brauchen könnt ihr
euch am besten mal aufschreiben wenn ihr
euch den den command aufholen wollte und
zwar brauchen wir einen zaun einen sound
stones lab einem blade rott und eine
redstone das hole ich mir jetzt erst mal
und dann noch eben die redstone fackel
hinnehmen und dann haben wir hier schon
die ganzen sachen die wir dafür
benötigen nämlich einen eichenholz und
eine stein stufe einen lohn ruth und
einer redstone fackel finde das immer
noch so faszinierend dass diese redstone
fackeln einfach so rotes licht macht
wenn ich in der hand habe das ist
einfach richtig finde ich richtig cool
diese ganzen details auf die bei diesem
kula shaker geachtet wurden so jetzt
kann ich nämlich hier einfach mal den
zaun hinschmeißen zusammen mit der
steinstufen dann seht ihr schon bekomme
ich einen mini am osten und wenn ich
jetzt noch die lohnquote hinschmeißen
und die redstone fackel bekomme ich den
minions davon wenn ich jetzt den mini am
osten hinschmeißen der heißen diana
starb weil er
einfach mini ist der ist mega klein
wenig man in anderen am stand daneben
packe seht ihr schon die unterschiede
sind immens aber wenn ich auf diesen
amos länder etwas frau schweizer nämlich
einen er rutscht einfach runter dass es
diesen minions darf auf denen drauf
schmeißt passiert mit dem nicht das
heißt die den brauch menschen können
einfach zerstören wenn ich allerdings
meine minions darf auf diesen mini amos
schmeißt sehen wir schon wir haben jetzt
ihren kleinen mini und ich habe jetzt
hier auch mein minions treffen kann ich
wieder haben wenn ich im survival mode
trend ist dieser mini am ostend
natürlich weg den lassen jetzt aber
einfach mal dadurch im creative mode bin
und jetzt kann ich hier beispielsweise
mal rechtsklick auf den machen und ihr
seht schon der komtur pulver und medien
ist said to follow you das heißt wenn
ich jetzt rein theoretisch einfach mal
weg laufen
seht ihr schon der medien kommt mir
hinterher gelaufen bzw er schlittert mir
so ein bisschen hinterher da das ganze
mit dem laufen mit der animation sondern
so ein bisschen lässt das ganze zu
wünschen übrig so kleiner mini geht es
ihr
was macht er ein bisschen behindert oder
sonst alles klar also wenn ich rein
theoretisch nach hier oben gehe dann
kann der auf wände hochklettern er kann
auch springen und auch wenn ich hier
unterlaufe kann er hier wieder
runterkommen ohne allzuviel zu entfalten
und bekommt dabei halt keinen fall
schaden also ihr seht schon das ist die
erste funktion dass er mir einfach
folgen kann rein theoretisch könnte ich
jetzt schon die zweite funktion und zwar
wenn ich in ihm drin stehe
seht ihr schon öffnet sich jeden moment
sein inventar das heißt minion inventar
da sind alle sachen drin
die ihr aufsammelt aber da geht's
aufgesammelt hat drücke ich nochmal hier
drauf und ihr seht schon wissen wenn ihr
es laut chief for you and pick up items
das heißt wenn ich jetzt rein
theoretisch mal hier in den sand nehme
und die hinlaufen hier den sand brocken
lastet damit er den auf und er kommt
jetzt quasi zu mir hin und wenn ich mich
jetzt in den reihen stelle und ihr seht
schon euch den ihm drin brücke jetzt
rächt sich mit den minions darf sich
schon sammelt erich die man sand item
auf genauso ist das ganze auch wenn ich
mir rein theoretisch noch hier so ein
bisschen was hole hier noch was von und
jetzt ist ja immer noch auf diesem modus
und ich lauf vor ihm weg so bleiben
flammen bleiben und blumen
der sammelt die ganzen teams auf und
wenn ich mich in den reihen stelle seht
ihr wieder
er hat wunderbar die ganzen items für
mich aufgesammelt wenn dann allerdings
irgendwann sind inventar voll ist wird
er quasi die nächsten sachen die er
sammelt einfach droppen lassen sohn etwa
und die werden dann einfach gedroppt
also die verschwinden nicht sondern das
ist wie sonne
diese mining turtle so ein bisschen also
da sammelt der die auf und dann nehme
ich mir jetzt erst mal wieder die items
von ihm zurück damit ich euch jetzt die
anderen sachen die noch zeigen kann und
zwar kann ich auch mit dem mit der mit
dem minions dafür einfach mal drauf
klicken und ihr seht schon
diskriminierend ist laut tadic das habe
ich eigentlich gar kein ton an oder so
eventuell hört ihr jetzt sogar was also
der medien geht jetzt nämlich hier nach
unten und gräbt sich jetzt hier voran
das ganze dauert bei mir irgendwie ein
bisschen lang ich weiß nicht warum es
fakten bisschen ab dass wir hier im sand
biom sind doch jetzt geht schon
schneller und zwar baute das jetzt hier
alles ab ich kann theoretisch hinter ihm
herlaufen und ein paar items einsammeln
die er nicht mehr einsammeln kann
allerdings wenn ich jetzt in ihm drin
bin sage ich mal hallo medien möchte
vielleicht mal bitte aufhören damit
nehmer kurz eine fackel in die hand
damit wir dem mann hinterher laufen
können und ihr seht fast das ganze hier
bedeutet und zwar gräbt er sich jetzt
wirklich bis zum bett rob und ich weiß
gar nicht wir sind schon auf über 28
mitgehen
so freunde jetzt hier unten gerade auf
dem redstone level angekommen und jetzt
kann ich ein theoretischer ebene fackel
hinsetzen kann ich ihnen reinstellen und
kann wieder sein inventar in der asse
schon er hat sand abgebaut bruchstein
sandstein ende seid und feuersteine und
jetzt kann ich durch ein erneutes
drücken auf den linien stuff wieder
drücken pickup items und jetzt bleibt er
quasi einfach das ist ein bisschen blöd
ist wie das ganze jetzt hier unten wo
ist er hin wo es eng ist er froh sein
das kann nicht sein
da kauft man sich einmal linien und dann
ist er hier seht ihr schon dass er die
anderen items hat droppen denn hin mein
kleiner racker bay komm zurück er kommt
egal manchmal einen neuen ihr nee das
ist dumm wenn ich mitmache weil er sich
dann eher wieder nach unten geht ok ich
glaube ich muss mir neun machen
der kommt irgendwie nicht wieder
gutmachen halten 9 so haben wir hier
neun linien auch jetzt haben wir sogar
den sound was passiert wenn ich in
kreiere also hier wieder die ganz
normalen funktionen jetzt folgt er mir
ganz normal wenn ich noch mal drauf
drücke folgte mir und hebt alterns auf
so und jetzt liegt er aber jetzt will
ich das nämlich nicht das heißt
überspringen und jetzt seht ihr schon
hat er nur pickup items das heißt
genannten wie follow you follow your
pick up items jetzt haben wir volle
millionen pickups und nur pickup alt das
heißt wenn ich ihm jetzt allerdings im
schweiße lebt er die quasi für mich auf
das ist ganz cool da kann ich ihm passe
hinstellen
am ende von seiner monster falle und
dann stelle ich ihn quasi dahin und er
sammelt automatisch meine sachen aufwies
und riecht da sage ich mal
und wenn ich mich jetzt in den reihen
stelle und rein theoretisch mal mit dem
minions tag drauf blicke seht ihr schon
hat er hier die items für mich
aufgesammelt und alles andere was ihm
jetzt noch hinschmeißen packt er halt
noch dazu das heißt ihr dann wenn ich
jetzt hier wieder in sein inventar
schauer hat er jetzt hier drei
bruchstein reingenommen und so weiter
und so fort den sand kann er natürlich
nicht aufnehmen weil naja sein inventar
ist voll von daher funktioniert das
ganze nicht das ist die vierte funktion
also dass er items sammeln kann ohne
folgen habe ich mir hier so supertoll
auf meinen klugen zettel geschrieben
aber wir haben noch eine fünfte funktion
dieser medien beherrscht und um die
sonne geschienen das sagt mir mal dass
das video schon 278 minuten ist und zwar
wenn ich hier drauf gesehen ich schon
display nis novi sad und plate is set to
this mean i said to place tortoise sei
es richtig dass heißt ich brauch nicht
fackeln mitnehme und die hinsetzen und
es passiert auch nichts wenn ich dem der
fackel zu schmeißen also passiert schon
was das heißt er hat die fackel hier
toll in seinem super inventar drin wenn
er dann wieder platz hätte darin
allerdings kann ich ihm kohle zu werfen
das heißt ich gehe einfach hier zu
werkstoffe neben mir ein bisschen kohle
und wenn ich mir jetzt eine kohle zu
werfen
seht ihr schon kommt dass ein kleines
feuerchen und eine kohle bedeutet vier
fackeln das heißt wenn ich jetzt weg
gelaufen wird er wenn in seinem umkreis
von sechs blöcken keine fackel steht
wird er dort eine fackel hinsetzen und
da er folgt und ich jetzt rein
theoretisch mal die hinlaufen seht ihr
schon er hat jetzt dahinter hingesetzt
da hat er eine hingesetzt
hier schwimmt dann natürlich gerade
durchs wasser was sehr sehr klug ist
okay wahrscheinlich hat er fackeln
unterwasser hingesetzt den medien hat
sie wieder sehr sehr gut gemeint aber
ich zeige es euch mal noch mal und zwar
schmeiße ich mich in der kohle hin
er wird ein bisschen feuer erhitzt hier
gerade eine fackel hingesetzt das seht
ihr
und wenn ich jetzt rein theoretisch noch
ein bisschen weiter laufen setzt er
jetzt hier wieder genau die fackel hin
dann laufe ich immer noch ein stückchen
dann setzt er dort irgendwo genau dann
setzt er dort wieder eine fackel hin
und jetzt rein theoretisch letzte hier
wieder den fakten hin und jetzt kann
nämlich keine fackeln mehr setzen weil
er jetzt keine kohle mehr hat ihr seht
schon eigentlich müsste der ziele noch
eine fackel hinsetzen wegen 6 block
radius von der letzten fackel
allerdings müsste ich im dafür noch mehr
kohle hinschmeißen das heißt ich habe
ihn jetzt so viel kohle hingeschmissen
das jetzt irgendwie 20 kohle hat oder so
das heißt damit könnte jetzt insgesamt
80 fackeln setzen
und ich kann dem aber auch rein
theoretisch 36 kohle zu schmeißen und
dann macht er halt so viele fackeln also
da gibt es kein limit wasser gesetzt so
wie bei mir im inventar das sich nur
irgendwie diese anzahl von stacks also
irgendwie neunmal 436 essex fackel mit
mir tragen kann
er kann rein theoretisch 7 millionen
spektakel mit sich tragen und heike
meier freut sich es kannst du dich
gehüpft und das ist die letzte wille die
bzw funktionen die die familien erfüllen
kann es ist quasi sein ständiger
begleiter auf euren wegen und diese
fackel sache ist vor allem ganz cool
denn irgendwie einer höhle seit oder so
kann euch ganz gut bei unterstützen kann
währenddessen aber noch items einsammeln
wenn ihr dem die bildete zuteilt und so
weiter und so fort also mega cool
gemacht und ich denke ihr wisst schon
des videos jetzt schon mega lang und
wenn ich jetzt noch zwei weitere bands
vorstellen würde wird das video über 20
minuten gehen
was war für euch sehr cool wäre
wahrscheinlich allerdings für mich im
schnitt wird das locker drei stunden
dauern und da ich noch andere videos
vorproduzieren muss wie beispielsweise
ag.de en kommt morgen sonntag mache ich
mal wieder was mit kommentaren und so
weiter
kommentare lesen und so in etwa deswegen
das muss noch alles produzieren und
deswegen sag mir bitte verzeiht es mir
das wiso mache ich das illuminaten
zeichen das ist ein bisschen komisch
bitte verzeiht mir das heute nur einen
command kommt und dienstag auch noch ein
command und nächsten freitag auch noch
ein command dafür sind halt immer so
umfangreiche commands wie die samen
ihren command ich habe jetzt ganz auf
command gesagt wenn euch das video
gefallen hat will ich mich um eine
bewertung freuen schreibt mir doch meine
kommentare ob ihr schon mal in amerika
war